medical workers in China are fighting a
battle for the world in some cases
without adequate protection more than
1700 nurses and doctors have so far been
infected several have died many of them
look so exhausted in front of the camera
and when you're exhausted you will get
infected because you just lost your
elderness
and you you cannot follow the guidelines
well last week the Chinese government
conceded there was a shortage of
essential medical equipment including
protective clothing but state TV says
that's changing now it's been showing
pictures of army medical teams arriving
at the epicenter with specialist gear
further proof says China of its
intensifying efforts to control the
virus a virus that the country's foreign
minister says has created excessive
alarm among some governments Duncan
winter will pass and the spring is sure
to come China's vigorous and thorough
measures are paying off the epidemic has
posed a severe challenge to China's
economic and social development
nonetheless the difficulties will be
temporary and short-lived the latest
official figures from China's national
health commission offer a crumb of
comfort these latest figures don't show
a significant drop in the death rate but
the number of new infections in Hebei
province is falling
they were half what they were on
Thursday but experts outside China urge
caution saying these figures can't be
independently verified analysts say it's
become a pivotal moment for China's
leader Xi Jingping if this works and it
looks like this thing is contained and
they get you know thumbs up from the
World Health Organization and other you
know epidemiologist it's gonna look like
they've done the right thing and he
could come out of this looking well but
at the moment it's it's such a girl on
Saturday China's government extended its
quarantine restrictions to the capital
Beijing anyone returning to the city
following the extended Lunar New Year
holiday must now isolate themselves at
home for 14 days state media says those
who don't will be punished without
specifying what that will mean in Hong
Kong the infection rate
is under sixty with one dead now the
chief executive Carrie Lam says the
government is to spend more than four
billion dollars of taxpayers money
helping workers affected by the virus
she says around 200-thousand low-income
families will be given a one-off grant
of more than six hundred dollars each
but there's no help yet for many small
to medium-sized businesses which are
reeling from the effects of this public
health emergency Adrian Brown al-jazeera
Hongkong